one of the most defining experiences of
my life was living in moscow for two
years it's uh really where uh i feel
like i became an artist i got to study
at the the famous moscow art theater you
know it was chekhov's theater it was
stanislavski's theater moscow was
completely alive and you could feel this
sense of history that was palpable on
the streets because so many of the
people that i i studied with and learned
from you know they had grown up under a
completely different kind of system
during soviet times
public gatherings were outlawed there
was no
way to get together and to express ideas
and to share ideas the only place really
where you could do that was in the
theater in these state-sanctioned
theaters and the art that was made in
these theaters had to have a pro-state
message meyerhold who uh was one of the
most revered directors in the history of
the moscow art theater and meyerhold was
assassinated by the kgb in his apartment
there's a palpability of this kind of
danger that exists on the street in
moscow the brutality of that city at
times really sickened me i was also
overwhelmed by the beauty of the people
and the beauty of the spirit and the
beauty of the art it's also given me
this sense of such a deep appreciation
for this country and how sacred this
freedom that we have is we spoke to uh
one of my very dear friends uh in russia
these are dangerous times and i think
that this perspective uh is unbelievably
valuable i hope you listen with an open
heart and again this is the perspective
of somebody who i consider to be one of
the realest ones out there
[Music]